It is Cyber Monday,
the online shopping day
where you can throw away
all the money you saved
at the stores on Black Friday!
And congratulations, by the way,
to those of you who survived
Black Friday, that capitalist
spectacle where shoppers
from all walks of life come
together to spread holiday cheer
and punch their fellow man
in the (bleep) face
for a kid's toy.
Like these thrifty customers.
-Ready?
-Yeah. -MAN: Yeah.
-No!
-(overlapping shouting)
-Whoa! Whoa! Whoa!
-(indistinct shouting)
(sighing):
Oh!
Wow. Look at those savings.
His life is half off!
(laughter)
-These... these... sons...
-(applause)
Hey, no. Stop it, Pete. Stop it.
-Uh... these...
-(laughter)
These poor S.O.B.s
trampling one another
like spooked buffalo
to get a deal on
electronic Panini makers.
This is an American tradition,
you guys.
But what about our neighbors
to the north?
Check out this video posted
by Suzette Belliveau.
This is how they do Black Friday
in Canada.
-Oh, God!
-(laughter)
-Aah!
-(applause and cheering)
-Oh!
-(whooping)
HARDWICK (laughing):
Those...
See, these polite consumers--
they may not have died
in a mall, but they will meet
their end years later
being gored by a moose
while drinking Labatts
over an ice fishing hole,
-or, as Canadians call that,
natural causes. -(laughter)
So, comedians, what are some
announcements
you would you hear over the P.A.
at Canadian Black Friday?
-Peter Holmes.
-Hi, Chris.
Hi, Peter.
How about, "Attention Canadians.
"If you're out of cash,
don't worry.
"We also accept check,
credit card, firm handshakes,
-eye contact and tickles."?
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
HARDWICK: All right, yeah.
Points. Points.
Very nice.
Joe DeRosa.
Canadians, let us all enjoy
this peace while it lasts,
because America will
be attacking us very soon,
because President Trump
has a tiny, tiny,
tiny, tiny penis.
(applause and cheering)
HARDWICK:
Points.
(with Canadian accent):
Also, clean up on Aisle A.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
-Come on, you guys.
It was right there. -Yeah.
How would I not?
I'm never gonna be welcomed back
in Canada again. Hari.
Attention, Canadians--
$50 healthcare.
You sign up for healthcare,
we give you $50.